les masques sont très rares tout comme
le gel hydroalcoolique alors pour faire
face à la pénurie un pharmacien parisien
s'est lancé dans la production et c'est
une véritable usine à ciel ouvert de 60
personnes et qui s'est installée dans la
rue dix mille litres de gel sont
produits chaque jour à destination des
officines
ce pharmacien qui travaille dans un
laboratoire a obtenu une autorisation et
des pales ainsi elle ses confrères
écouter horrible on a commencé à faire
ça dans préparatoire après on a fait nos
cultures et puis l'an fur à mesure des
demandes incessantes et permettant de
mobiliser la rue c'est à dire que ce
soit 150 mille personnes en france
auront un ingénieur accueillis dans la
poche qui viendra plus ou moins ici
pharmacies des hôpitaux les pompiers et
la police et forces de l'ordre en
général mais aussi des boulangers les
bouchers ceux qui continuent de
travailler qui ont besoin d'avoir un
missionnaire alcoolique dans la poche
venir ici c'est la formule de l'om est
ce que fabriquent le labo centralisée
delpech ça nous dépanne bien il ya
besoin besoins énormes pour les
infirmières les maisons de retraite
j'ai pris 30 litres ça me fait ça me
fait une dizaine de jours à peu près une
semaine dix jours